WILL NEED ALL 218 VOTES, HALF
THE HOUSE.
>> Todd: INTERVIEW WITH HUNTER
BIDEN ABOUT ART GOING OFF THE
RAIL AFTER THE PRESIDENT'S SON
DISCONNECTS WITHOUT SAYING
GOODBYE.
THE PODCAST HOST COMPLAINING
CERTAIN TOPICS WERE --
>> ASK QUESTIONS AND DEBATE LIKE
A FREE MIC, ANYONE COULD ASK
QUESTIONS, WE LET DEBATE HAPPEN,
THIS IS FIRST TIME WE WERE LIKE
[BLEEP] HANDS TIED, THESE ARE
QUESTIONS YOU ASK, YOU CAN'T ASK
OTHER QUESTIONS AND BRO, IT WAS
DIFFICULT.
>> Carley: JOE CONCHA IS HERE
NOW, CRYPTO-ROUND TABLE, WHAT
WAS OFF LIMITS?
>> Joe: THAT SOUNDS FUN, COUPLE
QUOTES STAND OUT, A LOT OF
STORIES I WASN'T AWARE OF THAT
MADE THIS MORE TRICKY AND
DIFFICULT, WHAT STORIES WEREN'T
YOU AWARE OF?
MAIN-STREAM MEDIA HAS BEEN ALL
OVER THE HUNTER BIDEN LAPTOP
STORY.
SARCASM.
THERE ARE QUESTIONS YOU ASK, YOU
CAN'T ASK QUESTIONS, IT APPEARS
HUNTER'S PR FOLKS, NOT ABLE TO
BRING IT UP.
WHEN HUNTER DOES INTERVIEW, IT
NEVER GETS BROACHED, IT IS ABOUT
ART OR DRUG ADDICTION.
THERE WILL BE QUESTIONS AS FAR
AS HEARINGS, I WONDER IF HUNTER
GETS SUBPOENAED?
>> Carley: MORE SERIOUS THAN
ROUND TABLE.
>> Joe: AND THE LAPTOP VERIFIED
E-MAILS, INFLUENCE PEDALLING IN
UKRAINE AND MAYBE CHINA AND
EXPLAINS WHY JOE BIDEN WAS
SOFTER THAN THE BEARS DEFENSE ON
XI JINPING YESTERDAY.
>> Todd: QUESTIONS ABOUT ART,
WHAT WAS YOUR INSPIRATION TO PUT
A STRAW IN YOUR MOUTH?
WHERE DID THE 500,000 GO AND WAS
THAT PAYMENT TO JOE BIDEN?
A LOT OF STRAWS.
"THE VIEW" HOST DELIGHTED AFTER
ARIZONA CANDIDATE CARI LAKE
LOST.
>> FORGET TRUMP AND DESANTIS,
CAN I JUST DANCE ON CARI LAKE'S
GRAVE?
TELL REPUBLICANS TO GET THE HELL
OUT AND THEY DO, THAT IS WHY YOU
LOST.
>> Joe: WHY WOULD A REPUBLICAN
STRATEGIST --
>> Carley: IS SHE STILL A
REPUBLICAN?
>> Joe: I BELIEVE SHE STILL SAYS
SHE IS, SHE IS THE CONSERVATIVE,
SAME PERSON WHO ENDORSED JOE
BIDEN, CHARLIE CRIST AND RON
DeSANTIS AND WANTS TO DANCE ON
CARI LAKE'S GRAVE.
SUNNY HOSTIN CLAIMED
YESTERDAY -- ZERO EVIDENCE OF
THIS WHATSOEVER, THERE IS NOT A
MEGHAN McCAIN THERE, THIS
CONTINUES TO GET SAID ON
NATIONAL TELEVISION AND THERE
ARE PEOPLE OUT THERE THAT
BELIEVE IT.
REMEMBER THIS FALLS UNDER ABC
NEWS UMBRELLA, THIS IS NOT AN
ENTERTAINMENT SHOW.
>> Todd: AND CACKLING SEALS IN
THE AUDIENCE GO TELL MIDDLE
AMERICA AND THE RUMOR SPREADS.
>> Joe: PROBGANDA.
>> Carley: AND THERE ARE PEOPLE
CALLING FOR THE VOTING AGE TO
GET TAKEN TO 16, THAT IS TRUE.
I NEVER HEARD 28.
>> Joe: GUY